welcome back to New rockstars and with
this week being a big week for both
quantumania and Guardians of the Galaxy
Vol 3. what if I told you that these two
big baddies could have a lot more in
common than you think what if I told you
that Herbert and Kang were actually two
black brothers from another mother this
is real clearing the show where he pitch
the wildest theories for the nerdy
towels that we love my name is Mt and
going well with me today is the lovely
amazing Jessica Clemens what's going on
Jose
um my cat just took a poop in her litter
box and it was wafting into my office
right now so if you see me doing this
it's not because I don't think you're
funny it's because I can taste my cast
no it's okay I'm used to that uh gesture
for women when I approach they're just
like
have you seen it before
and the wickedly talented and hilarious
Whitney van laningham is with us what's
going on Whitney hi oh my god I've
always wanted to be introduced just like
Adele design that's perfect
and of course it's my brother Brandon
bear what's going on Brandon hello Mt I
mean you bring up Adele nazim uh John
Travolta's famous flub did you guys see
his Super Bowl commercial yes that's not
real right that's a fake beard right I
like his bald heads actually the bald
head's fine but let the beard go let the
beard look so strange
this is Terry Crew's face
how dare you how dare you yeah
but he's trying to be me like yo like
sort of I I sort of put myself in John
Travolta's position because I just love
Zach Braff and Donald Faison so much uh
so like I'm just gonna be like
pretending to be scrubs you literally
fed into what they did in that
commercial there was no point for those
two to be in that commercial for either
of them to be there but I love scrubs
yeah I love scrubs so it's literally
what the probably the best TV show ever
in my opinion just love that show whoa
shots fired at Breaking Bad No hospital
TV show I forgot to say hi okay okay
shots fired at Saint elsewhere but
speaking about doctors uh we're talking
about some really smart dog people with
probably doctor's degrees because Kang
in the high evolutionary
um are very too smart black people that
came from Earth but I feel like these
two have known each other in the past
and the king of the high evolutionary
have worked together and here's why I
feel like you know with Kang being this
person that like is so interested in
Earth's past especially like we know
from the concept art that like he had an
Iron Man element and like he just is
very
like into like the the scientific
achievements of the past I feel like
Kang would go back and visit the high
evolutionary the smartest man with like
he is the smartest man with uh Evolution
genetics and with um cybernetics like he
made all of these people and with robot
body parts essentially so this guy is
like essentially a Tony Stark level
person and I feel like there was a
pretty good chance that Kang could have
gone back to either confront or fight or
um work together with the um the high of
um with the high evolutionary
um in the past what do you guys think
about this like do you think that Kang
would be interested in making like an
animal Army because like that's what the
evolutionary essentially has I think
that's why I think it's more of a
variant of Kang because I think it'd be
more interesting that like if every Kang
had like their Niche this one came was
taking animals and tried to make them
into like he's like I don't want to
conquer I just want to make animal
animal dudes yeah
basically Sid from Toy Story but he's
experiments on Rocket Raccoon
that is essentially the high
evolutionary he is from Toy Story baby
and then miss Kang is just like he was
Sid's neighbor and he was like you know
what that looks fun and he decided to go
back in time and help him make freaky
little animals you bring up a real
interesting point uh Mt because I I'm
curious to see how our boy Herbert gets
off of Earth and like gets into space
and gets uh you know all the power that
he has because it seems like from the
trailer for Guardians right the world
that he was building there with the
animal people it looks like very late
80s early 90s Earth between the cars and
like the the fashion and stuff and it's
like if he's only been in space for like
40 years or something like how did it
get from there to there like who gave
him this power and it would make sense
that like Kang would do it because if
Kang is aware of the high evolutionary
he's either gonna We Know the Way Kang
works either stops them or he like lets
them do what they're doing because it
benefits him in some way so it would
make sense that he was like I know the
future and I need this guy to make weird
animal animal men animal people uh
because it gets me to my future right
like when when the he who remains who
was a Kang was running the TVA he
allowed The Avengers to do their weird
time high stuff because it was like this
works out for me this works out for me
in the end so I'm okay with it so I'll
let it happen plus they both wear like
shiny purple outfits kind of right he
had this kind of shiny purple outfits
they're the purple Bros but no I like
how you bring up this point about um you
know Kang wanting
um The evolutionary to like set up like
it's a like using him for his of his own
ends because like I have a feeling that
um the high evolutionary could
potentially kick start mutants in the MC
or in the cosmos of the MCU
um and so like with more mutants in the
in the universe that means more people
that can be in a war it's like hey I I
feel like Kane just wants to fight and
like just be in a war
that's right exactly and like if there's
no one to fight or to keep up with him
because like he has all these these huge
like the suit that can shoot out lasers
like it's gonna be boring you just gonna
be like yeah I'm just gonna conquer and
like stop on these people it's gonna
it's not gonna be fun so I feel like you
want this challenge so yeah exactly so
like if the highway burn your Conquest
you gotta earn them exactly like you you
can't just be like hey I have a hand no
handouts no no participation trophies
all right you got to work for it yeah
you got to work work work work work like
uh change the participation trophies are
disgusting disgusting he hates
Millennials just hates us literally
don't blame the Millennials for
participation trophies they weren't
giving them out it was the adults giving
them out to the kids they were
acceptable and when we were seven years
old playing softball we should have
known we should have wrote them said no
thank you adult I didn't earn this and
that's what and then and then afterwards
we should have said avocado toast
okay and that's how we would have been
better generation
how could you it would also make sense
that I like the idea too that Ken's like
oh this is another smart guy and I just
want to talk to him because we saw like
in Loki right when he remains was
showing the little figurines of Kang
right the first one I guess that was him
was he saying it was him uh he was
dressed like a little scientist yeah
yeah he's dressed like a little
scientist with his little like lab coat
and his little glasses on his little
figurine and even though it was just a
little figurine Jonathan major still
looked good in like a scientist outfit I
was like okay my guy come on you didn't
look that good as a scientist
he broke through his little suit his
little his little science labs
burst into the back and then he throws
me on the table this is my favorite song
I'm sorry it didn't happen it did happen
now honestly Jonathan Majors is so
goddamn attractive he really is unfair
He's the hottest Marvel villain like no
questions asked damn yeah sorry Corey
stole as yellow jackets
I mean he's looking pretty good in this
movie in the quantum media let me tell
you he's uh he's all ahead
oh no oh no it is interesting though
because if you know Shirley King the
high evolutionary is doing some high
level stuff no pun intended right uh so
yeah it's like why would king allow it
if not it has to be like his doing or
like at least like
it helps him in some way yeah and I
wonder if he gave him like some of the
technology to like jump start the whole
thing to like really get it going
um that'd be really interesting because
I think in um in the comics Kang has
actually helped from like an outside
Source I think it was like Maelstrom or
something like like someone time travels
or something it's like hey here's like
the secret to to evolving people he's
like oh thanks I'll use this
um thank you oh thank you
if a stranger on the street shows up
they say they're from the future and
here's how here's how to evolve people
you always take that pamphlet you always
exactly oh you take the pamphlet you
just hate it and I feel like
um I feel like Guardians 3 is definitely
going to start off with a flashback to
the 80s like Guardians 1 and Guardians 2
did and we're going to see how the high
evolutionary sort of just like took off
on his rocket and to the moon or to the
Moon to outer space
um and start off his like like um
evolutionary stuff in the cosmos I think
that'd be really fun I think it'd be
really cool if like we saw during that
flashback Kang he's like oh look at me
time to start some problems here's the
formula for evolving people because I
just had that in my drawer because I'm
I've just I'm really old I mean I mean
like it's like when bif Tannen steals
the sports exactly
being like here you go here's a here's a
pamphlet on evolving humans now is it
possible is it possible that the 616 is
the only Universe with a high
evolutionary
because if if he who remains is
controlling the 616 and allowing these
things to happen that happened up to
this point right right uh then if if
this if every other Universe I can kill
the high evolutionary because he was not
he was he was a problem for Kang for
whatever reason like 616 could be the
only one that has a high evolutionary
that got as far as he got like this is
the only one where like Herbert has
flourished perhaps do we know if the
high evolutionary has been to Earth
but in the MCU is he actually from
that's like the big question right but
the fact that he's making a counter
Earth that looks like exactly he would
have he would at least have to unless
there's another planet that mimics Earth
that's true that's true or he was a an
alien who saw Earth and was like I like
this I want to copy this style like I
think like the fact his name is Herbert
like that itself well we don't know in
terms we don't know if it's Herbert this
is true we don't know it's her he
doesn't know his name is the high
evolutionary which is not an earth
is a really dorky name you guys but no
but he also uses eight nine p13 which
are Earth numbers and letters so he has
to be before that's true he's like an
earth file like he he loves Earth and
like he's from like Quadra par or some
made-up Planet but he sees Earth and
he's like yo have you guys seen Earth
Earth is the coolest I wear Earth
clothes I use Earth letters and numbers
the inverse of that is that wakanda's on
Earth and doesn't use Earth numbers
right so like it's like there's people
on Earth that don't even use Earth
numbers
so this is true it's I don't know I I'm
just saying I'm also saying this because
I had to make a video recently where I
was like I don't think the high
evolutionaries ever been to Earth yet
but he could have easily been so that's
why I'm like do we know if he's been to
Earth because I made a full video on
this and now this is true he could
easily be a zandarian or something like
it's it's true like well he could also
have like a bit of a Peter Quill thing
going on where maybe someone in his life
introduced him to or things and then he
was like this is awesome they have
a song called Brandy you're a fine girl
what and then he was like I gotta get in
on this and now he's just like yeah he's
a big Fanboy because he's never been
there but he like he's like this is my
dream vacation like like when you
haven't been to Disneyland yet and you
and you hype it up in your mind you know
like maybe
it's like going to France it's like oh
my God I gotta get to France it's so
beautiful it's so pretty it would it
would be wild if like because when ego
was going around banging uh females
across everyone right and we have to
assume that like he's not just like
banging one female on each planet right
he's probably he's got to try his bets
around a little bit to find you're not
just gonna pick one girl for each planet
right you're gonna you're gonna yeah you
gotta put a lot out there so I mean that
would be wild if her is like also a a
child of Eco much like mantis turned out
to be and like Star-Lord and Herbert are
like half Brothers in a weird way like
that would be crazy stuff crazy stuff yo
yo it would be that would be absolutely
nuts that would be nuts oh my God that
would be such a fun surprise I would
love like two peanuts one more time say
it would be that would be not smack it
beat me nuts
mixed nuts mixed nuts with M M's in
there because that's just tasty baby
that's I mean like it's the best way to
have mixed nuts if there's no M Ms in
there what's the point
but no green no sexy green M M's
how dare they have a sexy agreement
Eminem hold hands with another woman how
dare let's vote on this
um the idea of Kang in The evolutionary
working together in like at some point
in the MCU because Kang is a sneaky some
some Bish what do you think Brandon uh
this is rogus's this is rogus as hell
like yeah they have I mean Kang's got to
be aware with this High evolutionary is
up to I mean I know he's a busy guy he's
got he's got all of time to look at uh
he's busy he's moving around he can't
even remember who he's killed he's got a
lot going on right uh but he's got to be
aware of the high evolutionary and I
think I mean I think they got to be
working together in some aspect or at
least Kang is letting him do his thing
he's not stopping he's like yeah keep
making those weird uh animal freaks I
love them I love them but I do think I
do think I like the idea
that this is the only High evolutionary
out there like Ken killed all the other
ones but this one was able to get as far
as he did because he who remains was
letting him do his thing I do like that
idea as well I'm gonna give it a rogus
and and back up Brandon on that one I
think that it's totally possible that he
killed all the other high evolutionaries
in every other Multiverse and this one
he's like nah but this guy makes little
animals he makes it little animals like
people let's keep him all right two
roguses what do you think Jess I agree I
think so I think it makes sense it's
sound
um I like it yep good to go all right
I don't have a gun to my stomach under
my desk right now saying to go rogus
gun to your stomach what is happening I
think it's great
please oh please thank you guys this is
amazing you know I really it's about to
continue on with what Brandon was saying
like if I I like this idea of King
eliminating High evolution Aries
throughout like different timelines
because if you think about it the high
evolutionaries trying to evolve himself
and we see at like at some point in the
trailer he's floating with his mind I
don't know how he's doing that but he's
just like meditating he's like might
have evolved to the ultimate life form
and like I think that that is a threat
to uh to Kang he's like you know what I
need to like make sure that there's one
version of Baha'i evolutionary that is
like weaker than me but like you know he
ends up being defeated by the Guardians
of the Galaxy because you know they take
care of him
um so yeah I like that idea but like I I
can see them working together at some
point in the past because I feel like
Kang uses people because like like he's
using Modoc like he's using um um Scott
Lang and his family so I think I think
it both could happen uh but yes this is
great thank you guys for listening to my
theory but up next Brandon has a really
nice Theory and an amazing Theory um for
you guys but first be sure to check out
nerdriot.shop where you can grab a piece
or two of our awesome new shirts
inspired by Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania let the world World know
that you are no stranger to the quantum
realm there's also merch inspired by our
other fan favorite properties like The
Last of Us black panther Loki and so
much more in and it's a great way to
show off your fandom you can support the
channel and check out all of our awesome
nerd options over at nerdriot.shop but
we also want to remind you guys to check
out the Deep dive it is the latest
channel from new rockstars that we
launched this weekend on the Deep dive
Eric Voss will be going even deeper into
the films and series that we all love
exploring the hidden meaning and details
that you may have missed on your first
second or even fifth viewings so right
now on the channel you can find his deep
dives into Loki and one division along
with a deep dive into the
oscar-nominated everything everywhere
all at once which is my favorite movie
of all time love that movie we're really
excited to be bringing this new channel
to all of you so we hope that you'll
check it out along with all the awesome
content we'll still be bringing you
right here on new rockstars now it is
time for our second topic for today
which will be brought to you by Brandon
Barrick the coolest man alive take it
away Brandon ah the coolest man alive
you'll have to kill me to be cooler than
me
um okay so I have a rogue theory for all
right don't kill me oh hey hey hey hey
this is going to be used in the court of
law
okay I have a wild Rogue Theory it's
kind of two Rogue theories tied into one
so I'll throw them both at you at the
same time I think that the quantum realm
is a great place to hide out for people
we've seen that we've seen there's
refugees living down there they gotta
they gotta find their their spots but I
think there could be a key member of the
MCU hiding out down there as well and I
actually have two candidates for this
okay okay I'm gonna go with my first one
first which makes the most sense my
first one is a Nexus being
that knows has already transversed the
Multiverse and knows how to do it and
wants to keep doing it and needs a new
way to do it because their previous way
of transversing the Multiverse was kind
of destroyed and they're kind of on the
Run they're hiding a little bit I'm of
course I am speaking on the great the
always good the never evil Scarlet Witch
okay hear me out uh when we saw Wonder
core Mountain get collapsed and we saw
the red poof yeah I think our little
baby wanted to maximoff she poofed her
way into the quantum realm because she
needs to hide right now right people are
angry the 838 is really pissed okay
they're coming for her uh people on
Earth still piss there's people in New
Jersey who are still pissed Agatha's
gonna be coming forward too right but
she so through the darkness New Jersey
does not count as being part of no
they're separate
completely not only did you piss off 838
but you also pissed off New Jersey
you come for New Jersey you come for all
of us
so yeah I think she's hiding down there
uh because she can't dreamwalk anymore
because she needed the dark holder dream
walk I don't think she had memorized the
spell which also someone memorized the
spell come on uh and now that all the
dark holds are gone right not just the
one in 616 but all the dark codes were
destroyed that's what we were told in
the book of Ashanti is destroyed uh and
she wants to be able to hop around in
the Multiverse so I think she found a
way to get down there and right now
she's hiding in the quantum realm and
that's where she's gonna pop out again
because she's got to be on the Run she's
got to be hiding and she knows she can't
hide on Earth because someone's gonna
find her a doctor strange found her very
easily on Earth in her little Orchid of
pain and Chaos uh so that's that's my
first candidate for who's hiding in the
quantum realm my second candidate here
you go this is gonna be a wild one all
right you ready is it man it's a man
we've been looking for him we're
wondering where he is I'm listening go
on
it's a man who's been in fused with
Quantum power from his multiple trips
through the quantum realm it's a man who
doesn't want peace he wants War he
thrives in war he thrives in the
battlefield I'm talking about Captain
America dude I think Captain America
Captain America I knew it everyone's
like where's cap right I think he's in
the quantum realm and the old man cap we
saw at the end of end game that's like
late stage cap he'll get there
eventually but right now he he's hopping
around the Multiverse right we know he
went back with Peggy he had that lovely
life there but I think he got tired of
it because remember back in Age of
Ultron when Wanda maximoff they she
showed every avenger their nightmare
right his nightmare was a world of Peace
it was a world where the war was over
and he just gets to live in peace and
yeah he wanted to go back to Peggy you
know he got a few good nights out of her
and then he was like I'm tired of this
dude I want my struggle I want my back I
got a few good nights out of Peggy
that's what I'm talking about oh my God
that's what I'm talking about okay it's
great it's fine but it gets tired after
a while
I thought they call her Peggy let's just
say that
absolutely he was like I don't know if I
could do this for the rest of my life I
can't I don't know if I can do this all
day yeah yeah I can't do this I thought
one thing that I can't do all day I
think I think cap from his multiple
trips during in-game and going back and
putting all the stones back I think his
body became infused with that Quantum
energy we saw that happen to uh Janet
right yeah uh and I think he's able to
access the quantum realm now on his own
uh and he just went back and he's like
I'm gonna keep finding universes where
there's Hydra and I can keep fighting
them and all this crazy stuff is he old
down there uh I think eventually he gets
old but he's able to control his aging
right because we saw what happened to
Scott when time was pushed through him
he Benjamin buttoned in front of us so I
think I think there's someone hiding in
the quantum room it's important to the
MCU that will be revealed later and it's
either the Scarlet Witch or Captain
America you're on our wrestling case I
right I like this I like this idea
especially with the Scarlet Witch
hanging out in the quantum realm and
just like just being like hey I killed a
bunch of humans
um I cannot come back like
Jersey's on nothing I am no longer
welcome at this Waffle House
exactly like she is not invited to any
Waffle House in the Multiverse damn
Waffle House is good y'all I haven't
been there in a while I've never been to
a Waffle House the lines are too
freaking long here in L.A it takes you
an hour is it good too in Texas there's
one on like every corner and I used to
go there all the time we have just
roscoes we only have like IHOPs around
here which is that's not a waffle house
that is an International House of
Pancakes this is true I'm a big pancake
boy I love pancakes yeah no I feel like
um knowing that the quantum realm is
sort of the gateway to the Multiverse I
can also see Wanda hanging out there
sort of plotting her next move now that
her plans with with America Chavez sort
of went you know upside down so I think
that's so great though she's yeah not so
great so like I feel like she could
probably possibly like be looking for
like Quantum the place where the quantum
tunnels are he's like all right now I
basically have access to the Multiverse
now so I just need to pick the right
Multiverse where my children are so I
can just steal them from there one slide
right in yeah
I like that
yes ma'am she said
look I'm only business here okay I come
here I do my job I say my quips and then
I leave so
um first off
I said this exact Theory and I like that
theory but my one fault against that
theory is does it match too much to what
she did in Multiverse Madness in one
Division and when I say that I love I
like Captain I like the idea of Captain
America being there more than I like
Wanda Vision or one division okay but
the reason I was like I think I could
see Scarlet Witch being there but I
think the only reason people keep
putting her in the quantum realm is
because we know the Mystic Arts people
can get in there that doesn't mean that
Agatha can't and that doesn't mean that
doctor strange can't so I think it makes
more sense for those two than Wanda to
be in there because we're seeing that
scene of her living on her own in the
middle of nowhere in one Division and in
Multiverse Madness do we really want to
do it a third time in the quantum room
yes all day every day one more Wanda
please I love it too I just don't want
to see this woman in the middle of
nowhere going through Pray Love Again
sure
she learns Italian the second one was
prey and the last one has to be
actually that is right that makes more
sense than what I said
when you think about it like Wanda is if
you think Wanda is still kind of a baby
witch I mean like she did read the book
yes she's very new like she has all the
dark hole knowledge but like what if the
quantum realm has like its own witches
and wizards and like if they have their
own magic and they have their own way of
doing things plus time time works so
differently down there she can really
you know she could spend a hundred years
learning down there but it's a second up
here right exactly it's like the
hyperbolic Chamber from Dragon Ball Z
so you can't see any any of Agatha or
Agatha's Coven in the quantum room
instead of Wanda I could see them trying
to get down there I could see them
accessing it but Wanda as a Nexus being
she's more powerful than all of them she
could like either hide herself what
they're looking for or like push them
out like block their entrance into the
the quantum realm yeah and the quantum
realm is a Nexus of timelines it's where
all the timelines seem to meet it's like
the place where you can time table so
like it would make sense for a Nexus
being to be in a place where all the the
Nexus I mean I don't think that's the
next of all realities but like it's I
think it's close I don't know it's close
um yeah they were I think the the
filmmakers described the the quantum
realm it's like the basement of like all
the multiverses right it's the
foundation on which they're all built so
yeah maybe her and cap are hanging out
together powering up together
loving each other she's she's done with
that robot man she wants a real man yo
it'd be crazy if cap was down there and
he like banged one of those weird alien
micro ladies and they had a kid oh no
the broccoli the broccoli man the
broccoli man yes
and we have Captain broccoli how many
holes do you have Steve how many hoes do
you have how many holes do you have but
like I I think it'd be really
interesting if we had like a a Captain
America kid that was from a Quantum
realm he's just like yeah a half bug
like sort of like a mantis like oh my I
love bugs from the micro dogs so much
like the micro not Comics bug was
actually an original member of Star
Lord's uh Guardians of the Galaxy team
okay but like the uh bug is Hasbro the
bug is like belongs to the actual
micronauts
um lore so like Marvel cannot use bug
but like I would be really cool if
Marvel Studios made like a hybrid bug
it's like their own version of bug but
make it Captain America's child it's
like I'm Captain America Junior and I
have a bug mom and uh Captain America
dad I love how everyone's every Avengers
child is really cute and pretty and then
it's a book for Captain America
because everyone would expect Captain
America's child to be the cutest child
of all time because of you know the
super soldier serum so she's like does
it mean
diapers or no does it
poops
not all bugs I feel like there's one bug
without a butthole wait I don't know you
can't be have no butthole if you be
eating yeah okay first off don't owls
just poop out their mouths well no they
I'll still have like a cloak and they
they push they poop out that stuff what
else what else our pellets are the bones
and the hair that they can't digest the
stuff they can't digest comes out of the
mouth as a pellet and then the rest
comes out of of the digestive tract yo
if if owls are pooping out of their
mouths they could like poop in like 360
degrees it's like
like a freaking like sprinkler
cloacas are wild they're they're they're
the most wild body part in nature I I do
like I like this idea of someone hiding
out in the quantum realm whether it's a
little Scarlet Witch or Captain America
it'd be really cool if we saw the
Ancient One
um like during some time during a really
long life she just chilled in the
quantum realm it would be really cool if
we saw her I'd be like oh hey Quantum
realm I think there's like a non-zero
chance that she's been to the quantum
realm I think she did in the first in
the first Doctor Strange she when he got
a peek in her mind he saw the quantum
realm yeah I think that like during that
trippy sequence when they went through
that weird light source they went into
the quantum realm oh I like that I think
it's only the sorcerer Supreme that
might have I do like that's a good idea
too that the ancient ones down there
that'd be fun she's not dead she's just
down there she's now I can't give it up
I can't quit life nobody time travel is
just really weird and like she hasn't
had a really long life and she's
probably went to different levels of
existence so like maybe since time works
differently there which it's just like a
past version of her it's like oh yeah I
don't know that I'm gonna die yet I'm
just here doing my thing and I just met
someone from a different time
um but I don't know be really fun I love
her I just I really like um
um that actress because she just did it
really just went in but all right guys
let's vote on this second Rogue theory
of Brandon's of uh like potentially
someone hiding out in the quantum realm
whether it be the Scarlet Witch or
Captain America but do you think it's
rogus bogus or ogis take it away Jessica
I think it's right I think there's
someone in the quantum realm I agree uh
I I think there is you're not gonna
explore a new planet or a new world and
not put someone important in it you know
what I'm saying uh yeah so or someone
like a superhero in it it's like uh we
should see someone come out of it that's
not ghost because she technically just
got exploded with a Quantum tunnel so I
think that part's Rogue is it being
Captain America or the Scarlet Witch I
think is bogus but I do think overall
it's a rogue that's fair that's fair
that's fair I would love it to be
Captain America I just think have
America's story I'm kind of like just
let I wanted to be an evil Captain
America though it turned him and turned
him evil you don't want to see me get
out of this Quantum realm that's right
I'm gonna kill everybody what do you
think Whitney okay I'm gonna go rogus on
Scarlet Witch bogus on Captain America
because I do think that Wanda had to go
somewhere after Mount wendigor and I
guess that I always thought that maybe
she was just like it was kind of like
the House of M storyline where she got
displaced and she doesn't remember who
she is but she could have gotten
displaced to the quantum realm why not
why not both uh so I think that that
part could happen I don't think that
they're gonna put Captain America in the
quantum realm however because I think
he's just too old I think that they
should just let him not do this anymore
like I don't want to make old there's no
handicap ramps in the quantum room
there's no handicapped around it's not
it's not the quantum realm is not
wheelchair accessible and that's the
problem but we're trying to fix that
right now we've got the plans from City
Hall but until then I don't think that
Steve Rogers would like do very well in
the quantum realm at the age that we saw
him last and I know that Brandon said
some about like time traveling and
whatnot I I don't know I think that he
stayed with Peggy I think he was bored
but I think that after all the
he had went through he wanted one
lifetime where he was bored so like I
think he did do his boring lifetime all
the way I think he served his time in
boring town
he just kind of wants to die so like
that was basically the whole point of
like Infinity war and end game it's like
hey when are you gonna hang it up cap
it's like you know what I think it's
time yeah it's time for everybody
everybody needs to go night night at
some point
it's very true what about umt what do
you think I think that this is super
super rocus I like this idea of uh like
one of these Avengers hiding out in the
quantum row it's the perfect way to like
put an actor who wants to do other
things
um for a while like put them in like
suspended status in the MCU just put
them in the quantum realm um so like
yeah I like this or like I like the idea
of the film Fantastic Four also being in
the quantum realm as well because we
don't know where these butthole families
at they're somewhere I feel like yeah
yeah at some point so yeah they could be
there too but yeah like I like this idea
whether it's cap or Scarlet Witch so
Rogue is for me double rogus for both of
them
thank you I guess that I'm in August
because I voted rogus Scarlet Witch and
then I'll take the average I'll take the
average on that but overall August thank
you Jess for the gift of bogus you are
thank you Jessica I know we don't thank
you nearly enough for the gift of ogins
Jessica is the inventor of August on
behalf of all of new rock stars and all
of our fans and all of our co-workers
we'd like to say thank you for your
contribution of August without which
without which we'd all be dead but yes
now it is time for our Rogue question of
the day you guys ready for this one I'm
ready
because now that we got our first full
trailer for The Flash featuring a time
traveling Universe hopping Barry Allen
we can't wait to see how the DC Universe
gets reshaped so for today's Rogue
question if you could time hop into any
film Universe then change it for the
better where would you go and what would
you change into any film universe that's
a good question yeah it doesn't have to
be DC or Marvel it can be anything oh
really yeah
I'm gonna go fast obviously are we
changing the the premise of the movie or
re-changing you can you can make
whatever change you want whatever change
you want here's what I would do I would
jump into a universe that I hold very
near and dear to my heart uh the
Jurassic Park Universe okay yes okay up
into there I would get in there
somewhere in between uh the lost world
and Jurassic Park three the one where
they went back to aisle uh new bar with
Dr Grant and all that somewhere in
between those two movies between two and
three I jump into there and and fix what
was going on there and we never get like
Jurassic world they never reopen the
park none of that stuff I just want like
an island where the dinosaurs get to run
Supreme and it's constantly like people
trying to come to this island to catch
the dinosaurs or to like steal their
technology like steal the genetics or
whatever and they just can't do it and
the island gets more and more wild and
yes dinosaurs still get out and get
around and get around the world and that
still happens but they never reopened
the park forget the park let the park go
uh it's more about a world where like
dinosaurs start running Supreme uh and
and there you go that's what I that's
where I would go and change that that's
really I like that's really unique I
like that a lot what do you just got I
would which I think this is no shocker
to anyone I'd go into the Twilight the
Twilight series
oh my God not only do I get to go back
home but I'm gonna get bit I want to
become a vampire I get to go home into
the darkness and become a vampire
everything that I've ever wanted and
because I'm a vampire and I'm long
lasting I'm immortal like uh Carlisle I
would just study which I say this all
the time if I was ever Immortal and just
a normal human but Immortal I would
study medicine I would travel and study
medicine as much as I possibly could and
then just help the world this seems
really corny I know this sounds really
corny especially something Jessica
wouldn't do but I'm always like if I was
stuck on the planet forever there's an
endless knowledge to medicine that
people just haven't reached yet why
wouldn't I just study medicine and
science my entire life be like a Vampire
Doctor Who I like Carlisle I would be
Carlisle and I would just keep switching
cities and be a doctor in different
cities they I mean I'd be making a
steady income I would be doing something
that is always always open and always a
vast knowledge so I was like yeah I
would just do that with my life so I'd
be a Twilight person wow
which is very nice
that's just great marketing right there
during Pride people are like holy
this girl this is the doctor we need to
go to
oh my God 100 I hope what you got Wendy
okay I guess that mine is real but it
affects the franchise I want to go back
in time
to the Fast Five movies and I want to
make it so that Vin Diesel is not mean
to the Rock so that we can still have
Lucas Hobbs in the face
because he's one of the best parts and
he's so like I'm sorry in fast seven
when he's in the cast and he just breaks
his arm out of the cast and he's like
Daddy's gotta go to work I'm like I need
more of that I need more so I want to go
back in time and stop Vin Diesel for
being a little butt to his friend so
they could still be friends and make
more fast that's what I want I agree
with that hardcore I kind of like it
always like makes me sad to seeing them
like Feud together so like I don't like
it that they're beefing I don't like it
I just want them to be friends I don't
like it when people have beef you guys
exactly it feels it makes especially
like in a universe had already lost like
Paul Walker which is like I was
re-watching like just Paul Walker Clips
to the fast franchise and again like
he's just so great he's so good
and like honestly I feel like Paul
Walker could have been Captain America
like real talk dude he could have
honestly like if he kept having a career
I uh he would a hundred percent be in
the MCU right now but yeah like if he
was still alive no doubt in my mind he'd
be in the MCU right now yes no I do love
um The Rock and that franchise and I do
miss him so like if we could fix that
that'd be amazing so I'm gonna give that
a rogue trophy for today because
friendship always wins over beautiful no
no beef please no beef let's just be
sweet to each other let's be so nice
it's always nice to be nice but that is
it for this episode of Rogue Theory with
all my nice friends I love each and
every one of you guys were all amazing
and you guys are extra Rogue I love your
brains so thank you to our guests
Chester Clemens Whitney van leningham
and Brandon Barrick to support our
Channel by checking out all of our
awesome merch over at nerdriot.shop and
as a reminder check out the Deep dive
immediately because we got some new
stuff launching this weekend on that
channel and um it's just stay tuned for
a quick preview of that Channel at the
end of this video because it's really
cool follow me at masterton follow new
rockstars and all social platforms and
be sure to subscribe to our channel here
on YouTube we love you guys so much and
we'll see you guys next time goodbye bye
[Music]
[Applause]